hey guys in this video I'll be showing
you how to make an animated bar chart
race you can really easily create one of
these with your own data in just a few
minutes here's one that I made it's off
the market capitalization or market
value of these five big tech companies
creating the animation itself requires
no code and can be done quite easily
however in this video I'll explain how I
was able to fetch scrape and clean the
data but if you're only interested in
the visualization aspect feel free to
skip ahead to that part fetching and
cleaning the data and are wasn't too
difficult
first I've loaded in some libraries our
best to web scrape tidy quant to fetch
stock data tidy verse loop read a string
art and reshaped too for data wrangling
cleaning and formatting I wasn't able to
find a data source that he'd give me
historical market capitalizations every
time so I had to individually get the
stock prices and the outstanding shares
to manually calculate the market caps I
first started by getting the outstanding
shares I found this website macro trends
that had the data for each company by
quarter and it was just a matter of
scraping them into art I use the art
best library an HTML table commands to
very easily get the data into a data
frame I actually have a video on this if
you're looking for a more in-depth
explanation anyway once I had the
outstanding shares for each company I
just needed the stock prices for that I
use this Heidi Kuan library in art which
allowed me to get the daily stock prices
all the way back to the company's IPO
with the help of a few functions I
joined the stock prices data frame with
the outstanding shares data frame and
created a column to calculate the market
cap I've been joined these five data
frames one for each company into one
giant data frame so I could see all the
company's data and then lastly I did
some data cleaning I pulled out the
quarter in the year and I called the T
command to transpose the data from rows
into columns because that's how the app
or using prefers the data if you're
interested in seeing the code I'll have
a link to that in the description as
well finally I exported my data frame as
a dot CSV I then moved to the flourish
web app to create the visualization once
your data is all ready you'll need to
head over to the flourish web app I have
a link in the description when you're on
the page go ahead and click create
visualization you'll need to make an
account but one
you pass that stuff an example
visualization will load up at the top of
the screen there's a tab for data and if
you click on that you can see the
underlying data the raising bar chart is
drawing from I'm gonna click upload data
and plug in the CSV I just exported from
R on the right side of the screen
there's a panel that says select columns
to visualize you'll need to configure
which columns have your labels values
and optionally categories and images
once I configured that I did a bit more
data cleaning to reading the labels
remove the top row that was unused and I
added icons for the different companies
flourish is it great out-of-the-box
solution for these visualizations and
does have some customized ability I went
back to the preview tab and played
around with the settings I picks custom
bar colors changed the image settings
made the x-axis fixed instead of dynamic
formatted some of the text and then
finally added a header and a sub header
once I was happy with my visualization I
named it and click export and publish at
the top to share it you also have the
option of downloading it as an image for
free or downloading the HTML if you pay
for premium features anyway I could then
share the visualization by link or
screen recorded so that pretty much
wraps up the video creating these
animated bar charts are really easy and
can essentially be created without
typing any code as long as you have the
right data set there is some
customizability in terms of aesthetics
so I'd recommend just playing around
with it until you get the result that
you want I hope this video was helpful
and again any questions or feedback
definitely be comment below thanks for
watching and I'll catch you the next one
[Music]
you